تسميها الحكومه اصلاحا وتصفها المعارضه
بالانقلاب النتيجه انسداد يضع واقعه
اسرائيل على المحك ما بداه نتنياهو مع
القضاء والمحكمه العليا وبخطوات نحو تشريع
التغييرات القانونيه ينظر اليها على انها
خطه محكمه وضعها لانقاذ نفسه من ملفات
الفساد ومنح الشرعيه لوزراء حكومته
المدننه بتهم جنائيه الاف الاسرائيليين
سدوا مداخل مطار بنغوريان في تل ابيب
تتصاعد الاحتجاجات الشعبيه ضد حكومه اقصى
اليمين والاحتجاجات اجبرت نتنياهو على
استقلال مروحيه الى مطار بن غوريان بعد
قطع المتظاهرين الطريق عليه في حادثه عزل
على اثرها قائد الشرطه الاسرائيليه ولم
يكن المطار بوابه سفر فقط لرئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي الى ايطاليا بل محطه لقاء
الزانيه بوزير الدفاع الامريكي
او المعارضه التي تريد اسقاط الحكومه
بحسبنا المياه
بنامك الامر يعتمد على النظر الى الامور
بعمق مهما كانت الاختلافات بيننا يجب
علينا البقاء متحدين في مواجهه اولئك
الذين يسعون لقتلنا كان هذا هو الحال طوال
حروب اسرائيل بغض النظر عن الصراعات
والخلافه بيننا رفض هذه الحقيقه يهدد هذا
الاساس الوجوديه لدولتنا